[Applause]
in the spirit
of spooktober we decided to make a list
about the top 10 anime massacres
but before we start we need to clarify
that the ranking's not about how good
the anime is
since there are lots of other factors
like numbers presentation
and the everlasting effect on the story
and characters so don't get
shocked if we start off with your
favorite shows immediately out of the
gate
however you're free to comment on how
the list should have been ranked
and also don't worry if your favorite
anime genocide didn't make the list
because if this video does well we're
planning to make volume 2 of this topic
so without further ado let's start
[Applause]
number 10 battle of alnis hill sticks
and stones sure break my bones
but ak-47 breaks the soul
what better way to start off a list like
this more than showcasing the
advancements of modern day warfare
after the events of the gate opening in
modern-day japan
episode 1 the japanese self-defense
forces jsdf gets deployed on the other
side of the gate
to find out and arrest the person who
orchestrated the attack on the japanese
civilians
however as soon as they landed on the
other side the jsdf were faced by clear
aggression in the form of orcs
goblins spears and swords it was only a
matter of time to show that it wasn't a
very wise move on the behalf of the
imperial army
because as soon as the imperial army
began the death march towards the jsdf
tanks
they learned the saying don't bring a
knife to a gunfight
and conversely we learned that in a
fight between a dragon and an apache
helicopter
the apache always wins
at number nine beast titan massacre foul
ball
to prevent aaron from getting into the
basement beast titan attacks in what can
be considered the bloodiest
one-sided baseball game in the history
of baseball games
beast titan flexed his pitching game by
throwing a handful of rocks
destroying entire blocks of
neighborhoods with each throw
to put the massacre size into
perspective beast titan in that attack
killed so many
to the point the air literally became
red from the amount of blood vapor in it
not to mention the soldiers who were
killed on the suicide attack as well in
order to give levi some time
which proves once again nothing good
happens when you go to the basement
at number eight the shinjuku massacre
bang bang
who would have thought a teenager making
gun signs with his fingers would be more
dangerous than a dumb teenager with an
ak-47
after broadcasting himself to all
japanese stations
hiro made it as clear as a newly cleaned
mirror could be that he hates japan
and that he perceives every single soul
in it as his enemy
as such he begins shooting with his
robotic finger killing people left and
right
till the death toll hits a hundred and
before that he murdered a total of 85
people
51 police officers and 34 special
assault team members
that guy sure doesn't have any tolerance
towards those
horrible horrible cgi crowds
number seven the uchiha clan massacre
families can be tough
now for this peak we could have easily
gone with madara versus the world
but we went with the uchiha clan
massacre as it had an emotional toll
here's some background on the reason
behind the massacre the clan leader
fugaku uchiha aka itachi's father
decided to switch things up plotting a
coup against the leadership of konoha
village
when word got around to the village
elders they presented the clan's
strongest young member with a nearly
impossible choice
wipe out his own clan for the good of
konoha or die with them
itarchi agreed to carry out the massacre
because he was first very loyal to
kanoha village
and secondly because he wanted to
protect his emo edgelord little brother
sasuke
in that two-man crusade itachi and toby
wiped the whole clan out
in one fell swoop the only good thing
that came out from the massacre was
not sasuke god no it was all these sick
wallpapers
[Music]
cosio
i count one little two little five
little demon
sheep what other suitable way could you
as a supreme being showcase your power
other than killing
thousands of people for me i would have
asserted dominance by watching off-brand
anime in public
because nothing really shouts supreme
being other than turning the volume up
for that sweet yamate called the side
drop
but for sorcerer's supreme irons all
gone asserting dominance came in the
form of five black
baby demon goats with each having
multiple food holes fused together
forming one big wobbly ugly ass goat
running down the enemy soldiers
in fifth place the rabbit's massacre
blender goes
[Applause]
holy sweet mother of jesus how can one
come up with the words to describe this
massacre
this attacks one's brain watching the
clip of this genocide
you wouldn't feel anything but
uncomfortable there's a reason why this
pick is higher than attack on titan
and it's called human barbecue party
from snatching people from their warm
beds to putting dozens in a bag and
killing them as if they were cracked
eggs in a blender
this shows certainly no easy ride for
the weak stomach individual
the person who came up with this piece
of art needs either some psychotherapy
or jesus in their life because that
scene where the rabbit takes a woman up
and proceeds to remove oh you know what
i can't continue i want to stay
monetized because frankly
i like to eat
and number four the special
administrative zone massacre
prank gone wrong kids if you have a
special power that can let you control
other people and let them do whatever
you wish
you gotta be careful when you fall
around because when you
joke and it bombs it [ __ ] bombs but
don't take it from me
take it from uncle lelouch who decided
to be the funny man while discussing
privately with euphamia about japan's
future
as he was talking to her lelouch
suddenly loses control of his geass
while jokingly telling her to kill all
the japanese
not being able to stop her there and
then leads to lots of innocent people
dying
young to old they all kick the bucket
guess there goes lelouch's stand up
career it was one joke lived
in third place the london massacre
carnage in the air
everybody's a nazi till alucard releases
level
zero in what can be considered the
ultimate flex move
alukar releases his true power after the
nazis
kkk klansmen and church creeps think
they've cornered him
alucard pulls the ultimate fu move by
devouring a portion of the enemy lines
and turning them into mindless soldiers
under his control
just like the ones who were foolish
enough to stand against him throughout
history
alucard releases them waves above waves
of tortured souls
turning london streets to rivers of
blood by far this is my favorite pick on
this list
just because of the sheer badassery that
came from that episode
the whole sequence was like a portrait
every frame
could be a wallpaper
second place the eclipse you are
entering a world of
pain now you think attack on titan aaron
seeing his mom killed was dark
you think goblin slayer's nameless
sister getting raped by little goblins
was dark
do you think the bunny massacre was as
worse as it gets
then why not try watching berserk this
timeless classic
will make you reconsider berserk's last
episode the eclipse was all the above
mentioned
10 times over gutz's companions were all
killed in the most gruesome and painful
fashion
his lover was raped in front of him by
his best friend
formally i had to point it out not to
mention the amount of physical pain he
had to endure
to cut off his arm in order to stop it
and what made that scene even worse
is the fact that griffith didn't move
whatsoever locking his sight on guts
while defiling poor kaska's soul and
body i have nothing
but mad respect to guts for staying
strong instead of breaking beyond reaper
number one frieza destroys planet vegeta
fireworks fearing the imminent threat of
a legendary warrior being born
king frieza destroys a whole planet for
being insecure
kicking off the events of the whole
dragon ball universe
now some of you won't like this as the
number one pick and before you dislike
the video just
listen hear me out okay we chose the
uchiha clan massacre instead of mother
are killing people
because how it affected the main
character's personality
okay we picked beast titans killing
spree for the death toll that came from
that episode
so it's only natural to put the
destruction of planet vegeta at number
one
because it combined both the huge amount
of death
and a huge impact on the main characters
and the story
the destruction of king vegeta's planet
became a part of the culture
and not knowing about it is just
downright blasphemy
right we hope you enjoyed the list we
tried to stay away as much as possible
from planet destruction pigs
because if we included too much of those
the whole list would basically just be
all dragon ball
as said earlier at the start of the
video volume 2 is under consideration so
if you enjoyed this one
let us know by liking sharing and
commenting
as well as of course by subscribing it
will give us a boost of motivation to
continue
until next time
you